[Music]
shelby is in little rock
hi shelby welcome to the dave ramsey
show
hi dave hey what's up how are y'all good
how can we help
what well i'm calling my husband and i
have just started babysitting
um my uncle was gracious enough to give
us your
financial peace university class when we
first got
engaged so we went through that with
them for about a year
and now we're ready to go um but i
graduated in december
i i'm nervous talking here on six days
um i am about to start having
to pay my student loans or they're going
to be
you're breaking up shelby you're
starting you're about to have to start
paying your student loans is the last
thing we heard
start again after you're about to pay
your student loans what
we're about to start paying our student
loans right now they're in forbearance
um but we want to get ahead of that
while
the interest rate is still zero um
and so are not accruing it's not zero
but
um they give us several different
options
and i didn't know which one is the best
to go with
although we plan to have it paid off way
before the 10 years
um but it gives you several different
options and i wasn't sure pick the one
with the biggest payment if you can pay
the payment and then pay more
okay you need to get out of debt as fast
as you can how much student loan debt
have you got
thirty two thousand and uh what's your
household income
uh with my husband and i both he's
variable he's a loan officer
um but averaging 92 000
for both of us so how fast are you going
to pay off 32 out of 92
um i'm not sure we so did our budget
breakdown yet just listen to me a second
32 and 90.
one year okay
that leaves 60.
follow me yeah i got it
yeah and that's 2500 to 3 000
a month and that means you're on beans
and rice
rice and beans and you are not going on
vacation
and you don't need to go out to eat you
don't need to see the inside of a
restaurant unless you're working there
knock it out fast with 2600
in discussion discretionary income after
um all bills and not good enough tighten
your budget
okay i want three thousand and in one
year shelby it's out of your life
it's gone it is gone
yeah one year three thousand times
twelve is thirty six thousand you're
done
boom you're gonna be done in under a
year if you do what i'm telling you
you're gonna make it at 2600 too
so you're doing the right stuff you've
done the budget you figured out your
discretionary income now tighten it up
tighten it up list have you got more
than one loan in there there's several
different little loans right
yes awesomeness list them smallest to
largest
pay minimum payments on everything but
the little one and attack them
i want you to get mad girl you don't
sound mad yet
yeah dave what do you mean i just want
to stroll out of debt
i just want to take my money she's got
2600 bucks i think strolling no
scroll but her voice i want her i want
to get ah
you got to get mad you gotta you gotta
get angry at this because this stuff
will kick your butt man
it will it's a fight it is and they give
you those payment options on there
to keep you in debt as long as possible
believe you mean navient doesn't want
you out of debt no they want to keep you
they want to keep you in a cage
like a little zoo animal and by the way
people i need you to have your eyes open
because in the mail
you're going to start to see more credit
card stuff popping through
here in the next 60 days like never
before also online
be aware keep your antenna up if it
sounds too good to be true it is
do not let your guard down yeah this is
a good time to get screwed right
it is it really is dave you can finance
a sweater now
did you know that yeah well i would have
to be wanting to wear a sweater first
it was the example like you could
finance a sweater and pay like 15
a month for like two years it's
ridiculous it's a 32
interest rate good lord but people are
buying it's that old lelway mentality
remember
way away because interest free that's
right this is worse
but again people aren't counting the
notes
honest we've got to do math you all
don't fall for it if you can't pay for
it in full you don't need to buy it
that's right that's your grandmother
rule
that is a fact grandmother said it and
grandmother was smart
and she lived in a generation when they
learned how to do math yup
and they didn't need a smartphone to do
it